look who we found it's mike soroka who's
going to join us for the broadcast
tonight great to have you here pal
what's a nice guy like you doing in a
place like this something different i
needed to shake up i needed to talk some
baseball and i couldn't think of a
better place obviously a second start
since being up after the dl uh and i
think what's important for him tonight
is is to continue dominating lefties the
way they've set up this lineup tonight
it'll be a good way to to manage that
lefty's hitting just 187 off of him
right now
uh it's going to be a good night i want
to see him be aggressive and stay inside
the zone all right so this should be a
good series two game set of red hot
teams as paul mentioned uh two teams
that have won at least nine in a row
have not met since 1901 so 120 years
and a swing and a miss le mayhew down
there's that devastating slider one up
one down for noah he has had that pitch
guys from the opening belt of this 2021
season so anthony rizzo he's completed
the holy trinity in baseball he's played
for the red sox the cubs and now the
yankees
rizzo fly ball to left long run duvall
still coming he's going to get there and
rizzo's retired on a soft fly ball two
up
two down
hit shortly and through for base hit
so it's 16 games in a row on base safely
as jones picks up a two out single so
runner on first two outs that brings up
joey gallo judge is running the pitch is
a ball the throw to second is going to
be dropped swearing judge six out of six
in stolen bases he'll reach with two
outs brings the 3-2 pitch got him
looking strike three
put a slider over the inside corner and
a very good start for wascarinoa the
strikeouts of la mayhew and gallo well
curves ahead and that is his favorite
pitch he uses it almost a quarter of the
time and why not batting in a batting
average against 172 k percentage over 42
percent swinging mess over 42 it's been
really good and when he's at his best he
has his good curveball but he is michael
as you said a team player
the yankees are 14 and eight when monty
starts and that's the best winning
percentage of any pitcher on the yankee
staff
up the middle
right there is lemayo
the shift had him played perfectly
one away alby's a good guy to keep off
the bases he runs well oh two
o'dual
to velasquez over the first night in
time so adore shifted from third to
short right field
and he made the throw to the shortstop
so he scored that 5-6 on the force as
freeman reaches on the fielder's choice
there's the 2-2 on the way
swung on and missed
that time buried a cutter low and in
riley swung over the top of it that's
the first strikeout victim for jordan
montgomery in the ball game no runs no
hits no errors one left we played one we
head to the top of the second here is
stanton
the 2-2 is hitting the air down the
right field line headed toward the wall
and she is gone
right next to the pole down the right
via line a stantonian home run and
giancarlo no suppose to follow
he homers to right and the yankees take
a one-nothing lead i mean stanton when
he uses the whole field this is the
slider but you see he got the barrel on
it didn't even have everything behind it
dan's be to lead things off here in the
bottom of the inning
fly ball by dansby on the first pitch
that's headed toward the bright bullpen
george brown it's gone again tired for
dansby swanson he extends his all-time
franchise record for homers by a
shortstop
first pitch
opposite field good approach great
result we're tied at one he just threw a
get me over curveball and right now the
way dansby's feeling at the plate that's
not a good idea the ballpark is jumping
tonight in more ways than one and the
payoff
that one's drilled to left field on the
run as gallow
makes the play
and heading back to first is contreras
gallow saved an extra base hit and
probably iran boy he takes great angles
to the baseball michael and i tell you
what he is a lot more agile than you
think i mean this might be the world's
largest outfield combined
and here is jorge
walked in the first inning that one's
driven into right center long run for
judge
put it away for the second house he
covered a lot of ground and judge just
made a terrific catch you know he's got
the biggest smile on his face when he
makes a play in center field he must
really love that he did this in college
i know this isn't this isn't new but he
really gets to run around out there
crashed into the wall andrew velasquez
rips the first pitch and rips it to
right field for basic it gets past
solaire and velazquez gets himself a two
out double we've talked how comfortable
he looks into the field and all of a
sudden he's starting to look very
comfortable on the ball inside you see
he hit that ball out the yankee stadium
the other day this ball was supposed to
be away
and the pitcher up now be up to him to
try to figure out a way to get him in
montgomery had his second at bat of the
year the payoff pitch to the pitcher
swing and a miss struck him out on what
is probably ball four
but he got him eight strikeouts for noah
and the two out double does no harm we
go to the bottom of the fifth so stanton
stands in
is it first and second with two out
that one is ripped to left field it is a
base hit and it goes up against the wall
scoring easily is lemayo here comes
gallow he will score it's a two run
double for stanton and it gives the
yankees a three to one lead
another great at bet by stanton he did
waste that fastball to get back to a
slider but then did not throw a great
one
yankees got a big break here by this
ball hitting the wall staying in the
ballpark and allowing allowing joey
gallo to score from first base three
infielders on the left side for sanchez
swing and a miss struck him out good
comeback by wasker but not before the
yankees get a hit batter
a two out walk and then a two out double
to take
nothing and two on rizzo santana lets it
loose come backer over the mound dansy
to his left gloves 360 spin and a good
throw to freddie freeman for the out he
went all the way over to the second base
side of the infield it really is a treat
to be able to watch dansby every day
i feel like he's finally getting the
credit deserves a short stop see his
work day in day out judge at third
gallows at second two men out yankees
lead three to one three two count on the
pensioner void
and he walked him so that'll load the
bases for gary sanchez and that will do
it for santana sanchez has grounded out
to short twice and struck out grounded
through for a base hit
one run scores here comes gallow he'll
score it's a two-run single for sanchez
a big hit and the yankees lead 5-1 well
good job by gary sanchez by not trying
to do too much so here is guillermo
herrera last chance for the braves to
stay alive
and this should do it velasquez fields
fires and the yankees have won 10 in a
row and the winning continues
they've won 10 straight
they've won 17 of 20. 22 of 27 and 32 of
43
and it's their first 10 game winning
streak since september
of last year and roy paul they have
everything is clicking right now